[Music]
it's gonna be a total disaster it's
gonna be a really long day
i hope this works since it's not the
prettiest sauce
looks great you guys this is like the
coolest thing i've ever done
welcome back to another episode of chef
out of water i'm alexis a chef who's
always up for a challenge we've taken to
the internet to ask you
what appliance i should use to make a
three-course meal
got something very large next to me
which makes me a little nervous
shall we see what's in there
what is it mini dishwasher
are these my tools i know you can make a
salmon in the dishwasher so i know
something is possible
i have absolutely no idea what i'm gonna
do but i do have heat
and i feel like with so many episodes i
just ask for heat
so i have something i need to do a lot
of research
okay let's see what's possible in a
dishwasher someone's tried to cook
chicken breast in a dishwasher which
sounds truly offensive
lasagna feels hard okay it seems like
there's a lot of
seafood that gets poached in dishwashers
with relative success
really good to know meat feels a little
iffy obviously the skin won't brown so
you get like
weird floppy skin i think i'm going to
stay away from meat today
it gets up to like 150 degrees to
sous-vide it needs to be between
like 131 and 140 degrees so
i think i need to look at this like a
giant sous-vide
the shortest cycle is about 40 minutes
and i need to be really smart about time
here i'm gonna try to do
everything at once gotta list ryan he's
gonna go shopping while i get my head
around this thing
we'll see what happens ryan
for my first course today i'm gonna do a
spring vegetable
salad with a sauce grabish gribish is
a traditional french sauce i think it'll
add some brightness
and i'm going to put it over asparagus
green beans and english peas
i think it could work my conversation i
feel like my emotions are so erratic
right now
i just like like a five i'm gonna get
some jars this really feels like a craft
project
okay so some beans i'm not totally sure
how much water
i'm gonna add a bay leaf some
peppercorns i mean if this
works it's gonna be really cool some
salt and
a lemon peel
[Music]
well one thing done i've got some
english peas i'm gonna do
exactly the same thing bay leaf some
peppercorns
salt a lemon peel
look at that this is like my little
laboratory
okay i've got some beautiful asparagus
here so i'm just gonna
have them on the bias let's do the same
thing
some salt bay leaf some peppercorns
a lemon peel
[Music]
looks great i'm worried about the eggs
like
knocking into each other so i got you
know i only need one for the dressing
but one more egg oh no
okay yeah
maybe making it a little more secure a
little more snug it's a little egg mist
of course one for my second course
i'm going to make butter poached lobster
tails
and then make lobster rolls from the
tails i mean this seems so weird but
i'm gonna put the tails in the jar
and then put the butter and some water
adding some garlic cloves might add some
flavor
more lemon peel and salt
oh this is so weird moving on to dessert
for my third and final course i'm going
to make
poached strawberries and make kind of a
parfait
first i've got to start with my
strawberries i could haul these which
just means like using the tip
to go all the way around the stem
and then you just pop it out like that
quarter inch feels nice
it feels good on the strawberry front
you can add some water
and some sugar
[Music]
sugar oh my god i've done that so many
times
oh no oh no did i seriously just put
salt
i cannot be trusted some
lemon i also have a vanilla bean
which i thought would really like infuse
it with that amazing
flavor you want to split it down the
middle open it up
and then use a paring knife to press
down
and scrape the seeds oh my god it's like
gold and i'm actually going to add the
pods in too because
it's just more flavor this is my meal
my entire meal is right here it's
dishwasher time
great off to a great start
fill it with water
god this is small first i'm gonna put my
lobster in and my eggs
just nestled nice together and then i've
got my
peas my green beans and asparagus
and then my strawberries easy
this is crazy here goes nothing
okay i'm gonna put it on baby care which
is gonna be like the steamiest
it's also two hours my god this stuff is
gonna
cook way sooner than two hours
[Music]
okay well this gets going i'm going to
whip some cream
and smash some cookies for my little
parfait
i've been here so many times before i
can't believe i keep
choosing to do it again
okay whipped cream is looking swoopy
okay
wow back to the cream just a little bit
of sugar
whipped cream i'm gonna have ryan put
this in the fridge and then i'm gonna
smash
some of my cookies some people might say
that this is cheating a little bit
because i'm using store-bought cookies
but
you're not making the meal with the
dishwasher so my journey
that's it we just gotta wait for uh this
food to cook
i thought two hours was gonna be way too
much time but i just did a little more
research
and it turns out for both eggs and
lobster
they sous-vide for about an hour at 1 35
and it's been 30 minutes
and it's only at 109 so i actually think
the two hours is gonna be perfect
i feel very relaxed right now my
emotional
level is like a ten my confidence level
for
the food is like a six
so my little dishwasher's been going for
about an hour and i just want to
do a little quick check to make sure
it's cooking or
something's happening oh wow she's
stainy
i guess we'll start by seeing how the
asparagus tastes
a lot of crunch not
bad but definitely needs more time it's
actually not that hot either
the beans have not cooked at all since
oh god
that looks um really disgusting
the lobster meat is definitely cooking
but it's still
not fully opaque so
it needs more time the eggs honestly i'm
not even gonna check they need more time
if the bean isn't cooked the egg is
certainly not cooked
i think i'm gonna let it go for another
like 45 minutes
she's hot 154. i let it go for another
hour
rather than 45 minutes but i think it's
ready
the lobster looks insane
it smells good well the tails have
turned red which is
usually the sign that they're cut to
open a lobster tail pretty easy
use some handy dandy kitchen scissors
and you just want to cut
the underside of the lobster and then
you can just peel the shell back
crack it open it's actually like pretty
beautiful
it's like really beautiful maybe we're
all gonna be cooking lobster in uh
dishwashers
i'm just gonna cut off a tiny bit to see
it's delicious it's like
delicious it's so
buttery this is amazing
you know even if everything else fails
this is incredible
my lobster is going in a little bowl and
i'm gonna dress it up with some mayo
some lemon for adding it to my bun
moment of truth on the eggs oh one
cracked oh
one opened oh god oh god some of the
yolk got out
it's pretty gross okay this one is still
fully raw and like snotty
oh my god gross the egg did not work
the egg was not great i have one egg
left in here
and i'm gonna put it back for like 30
more minutes
to hopefully get it because it's like
it's cook
it's cooking it's just not it's not
cooked
oh jiggles too let's see about the
vegetables
the peas ooh are leaky the peas look a
little
overcooked a little gray the color is
like
really not great
[Music]
but the flavor is fine they're a little
cooked
they've got quite a bit of crunch moment
of truth on the strawberries
which should look like a lot of their
color has been removed
smells incredible that's so good
it's sweet it's not too sweet
strawberries are cooked perfectly
they have a little bit of bite they're
not mushy eggs are going back in
[Music]
i'm gonna start dressing my lobster roll
i've got my
beautifully cooked lobster meat just
gonna add some mayo
some lemon juice a little bit of salt
that's it just lay it in there i like
seeing a little bit of red the meat in
my
lobster buns looks amazing i think this
is my treat
[Music]
it's so good and to add some chives on
top
my entree is done i'm so excited about
this lobster roll i'm gonna move on to
dessert while my egg finishes
cooking onto dessert i am gonna do like
a parfait
this is really exciting okay i'm gonna
do a layer
of my crushed cookies a layer of whipped
cream
a layer of strawberries another layer of
crumbs
oh wow poached strawberry parfait
maiden dishwasher complete
my machine has stopped so
egg time let's try this again
egg is cooked now
that is a beautiful egg for a grabish
i'd really like it to be
harder but honestly if the dishwasher
did this like no complaints this is
so cool got the chopped up egg i'm gonna
add some capers
and some corny shop little french
pickles
i'm gonna add some dijon mustard some
champagne vinegar
gonna give it all a stir it's not the
prettiest sauce and then i'm gonna just
drizzle in some olive oil
some salt pepper i feel like the
vegetables look kind of overcooked and
the sauce
does not look that appetizing i kind of
feel like this is as good as it's gonna
get
this is not what i envisioned in any way
oh
i needed to add parsley to it too sauce
gribish everyone there's a reason you
don't see it on menus anymore
i'm gonna add some parsley some flaky
sea salt
my confidence level on this dish it's
not great i feel
like 10 on the lobster roll anton
dessert but like
this three that feels
generous i think this is as good as it's
gonna get the good news is that it gets
better as the meal goes on
let's see what our taste tester has to
say this is my friend joyce
hi joyce i made you a
three-course meal today using this which
i will reveal to you after
okay that makes me nervous but i trust
your cooking
course one is a spring vegetable
salad with gravish which is a type of
french sauce that looks good
it definitely has the earthy taste to it
i like them you like it
health healthy this is very healthy you
know it gets better from here
for your entree i have a lobster roll
for you
[Music]
i love a lobster roll oh pretty
instagram me and bait 20 20.
wow that's delicious
for the last course i've got a little
poached strawberry parfait for you
this is what i deserve you do i deserve
this
every day
i'm gonna try it too it's delicious
oh my god you look really good girl
thank you
damn the big question what do you think
i made this meal with an air dryer
that's
not that far off are you ready to see
i'm so scared ready mm-hmm
it's a dishwasher first of all you get a
portable dishwasher
do i need that period second of all
how did you make this and that got to
watch the episode
damn girl you can really cook okay girl
well thank you
i have hopes to feed i'll see you guys
later bye
i wasn't sure what to think about the
dishwasher but turns out i love it
you can do so much let me know in the
comments what you thought of the dishes
that i made
with a dishwasher today see you next
time on chef out of water
[Music]
i feel really nervous ah do you think
it's gonna explode
i think the shrimp have betrayed me what
a struggle
back to chef out of water i'm alexis a
chef who's always up for a challenge
we've asked you internet to decide what
unconventional appliance i should cook a
three-course meal with i feel
really nervous but i'm ready to find out
what i've got to work with today
air fryer pretty good this feels like a
win
i have actually used an air fryer before
i have a good foundation of how this
works
i think i've got to do a bit of research
to find out what exactly
i'm gonna make but i feel really excited
this is gonna be great so airfryers
aren't that complicated there's a basket
so you can prop stuff up on it
the heat comes from the bottom and kind
of circulates it around they're pretty
simple i mean i know that's famous last
words but
previously i've made a roast chicken
i've made chicken wings jalapeno poppers
a bunch of chips like vegetable chips
that's pretty easy someone's made
cannoli before people are really into
shrimp coconut trim fried trim
you can make lobster tails in an air
fryer
i've got my grocery list i'm gonna have
ryan go out and grab a few things
and in the meantime i'm gonna get
started on what we have in the pantry
confidence is a solid seven i feel fine
i feel fine i mean how poorly can this
go
okay so i'm gonna work backwards and i'm
gonna start with dessert
i'm gonna make a cherry cake tart
torte thing which is based off a new
york times recipe which is super popular
foolproof i've made it in an oven so
many times it's never gone wrong so i
well i hope it works in the airfryer but
we'll see
first step is i've gotta put it
on power great
temp look at this and then start
i'm starting by creaming some butter
and some sugar if i was at home i would
use a
mixer oh this butter is certainly not
soft yet maybe i'll put it in the air
fryer to melt it a bit
for a second
this could be a terrible idea
oh oh no no no no great idea it's a
great idea
slightly melted look at that wow very
efficient
oh my god it's a great idea it's one of
my best ideas
now i'm going to add my egg
and it should make these like swoopy
ribbons and
some baking powder to help it rise pinch
of salt
just want to get it all combined and now
i'm going to fold in some cherries
using frozen cherries but if you add
fresh you could use that too
so i've got a little tiny tin buttered
it put some parchment down
i'm just gonna add the cake a little
cake is going in
see you in 15 minutes
yeah it's a little bird but also appears
to be a little raw
i don't know what to do i think i need
to do this again
okay i've made another batter exactly
the same
clean pan i'm going to do
a lower temperature this time i'm also
going to put it on
roast instead of air fry and cover it
with tin foil
i think between those three things it's
going to work a lot better
roast
my confidence level i'm gonna still say
a seven
you know i think he got off to a rocky
start but
something's gonna work while the cake is
baking i'm gonna get started on prepping
my next course
ribs with corn pudding i love ribs um i
didn't grow up with corn pudding and
have had it honestly like twice in my
life but it was really good
and it feels like it goes with ribs and
i feel like it's gonna work in here so
so i need my butter melted again but the
air fryer is occupied
this is a mess
i'm gonna take the cake out for a minute
i'm gonna put the butter in for a second
it's gonna be fine
i'm just gonna check on the cake while
my butter's melting
you know i think it just needs more time
it needs more time
still fully raw just need some more time
it's okay my confidence is waning
butter adding the eggs to the butter
gonna add some cornstarch
sugar some jalapeno for some heat some
salt
fresh corn this is creamed corn it kind
of looks like baby food
at this stage but it's gonna get good
oh and some cheese got some butter paper
towel
i'm just gonna butter the insides of
these ramekins and i'm just gonna fill
them with the corn
a little cheese on top okay my corn
pudding is ready
to go cake looks like it's ready also to
go
i mean we'll see 20 minutes 30 minutes
okay moment of truth well
it just it you know it needs some more
time
i think just for time's sake i'm gonna
have ryan
finish cooking this off with a second
airfryer
i'm gonna do one at a time so next up
i'm going to do a
no cook barbecue sauce for my ribs
typically you
simmer barbecue sauce to get it really
intensified with flavor but that's not
an option so
i'm gonna start with some ketchup and
some brown sugar some salt
black pepper paprika and a little garlic
powder
and then some uh worchestershire sauce
we're just for sure worcestershire
worcestershire we're still sure sauce
some worcestershire
if all else fails i've made some
barbecue sauce
i've got all the same ingredients for
the dry rub so i'm just going to throw
some of this together
salt pepper little brown sugar
some paprika some garlic powder mix it
together look at that oh my god
two birds one stone i'm just gonna wait
for the corn pudding put this aside
we're moving right along things are
going i'm going back up to a seven
two one
oh it's beautiful
oh my god it's wow it smells amazing
it looks beautiful oh my god
because i have two of these i'm gonna
save the second one and i'm just gonna
test this to make sure that it's fully
cooked inside it looks
oh no
oh no
well it's not cooked inside
why is this not working
maybe it just needs to go for longer
okay
moving on to the ribs obviously this is
not gonna fit in an air fryer so i'm
gonna just
divide it up a bit i'm gonna take some
of this
and just rubbing it over ribs remind me
of
the delaware county fair just reminds me
of like summer
being a kid you have no cares in the
world
are you gonna get another ticket to go
on the scrambler that's all you have to
worry about
not anymore kids my ribs are ready to go
so as soon as my second corn pudding
comes out i'm gonna pop the ribs in
well we just found out what's wrong with
this which is i forgot to put heavy
cream in it so it's not gonna set
my bad i'm gonna make another batch of
corn pudding i'm also gonna put them
into smaller ramekins so that i can do
two at a time
it looks beautiful though so i think
got high hopes okay so i've got a fresh
batch
of corn pudding batter
i think the smaller size is also going
to help them cook faster
and obviously the heavy cream is going
to ensure that they actually set
[Music]
okay 15 seconds just gonna do it
oh they're like little corn souffles
they look amazing
oh okay okay still
still raw still
wrong i honestly think it needs like
five more minutes and it's gonna cook
it's almost there remember this morning
when i was like
air fryer so easy yeah but they're
pretty
simple i mean i know that's famous last
words
it was a mistake i made a mistake ooh
okay they look beautiful it's bouncy but
it springs back
it's not raw inside looks good
i think i can finally move on from the
corn pudding saga
i'm gonna move on to ribs it's rib time
my favorite time
let's start with these guys
cool this is smoking but
oh my god they look insane like
insanely good not bad i think this is a
case where smoking is fine
obviously if it's billowing smoke i'd be
more concerned
it's fine so ryan finished off the cake
and let's take a look all right it's
pretty perfect
okay moment of truth it's actually
so pretty i mean it's tiny but it smells
great it looks so pretty
i'm really happy this worked it was not
looking good this morning
i'm gonna move on to my final course
which is actually the appetizer
i'm gonna make shrimp po boy sliders
first i'm gonna start with the remoulade
which is basically like a mayo based
sauce
it's got some relish some mustard
some hot sauce and some lemon
oh you guys i'm really nailing the no
cook sauces
and now i'm going to make a like spiced
buttermilk mixture that the shrimp can
just like hang out in for a bit
some buttermilk then some salt
pepper i've got some paprika oh wait
i have paprika and cayenne i think this
is cayenne
[Music]
yep holy
okay great so we've got some paprika
tiny bit of cayenne um the tip of my
tongue is on fire and some dried thyme
oh my god it's really spicy it's really
really spicy
give it a good stir adding the shrimp
and
you can just let it get covered like
that
loud guy she's getting just getting
crispy
[Music]
got my no cook barbecue sauce
backside too the ribs have been pasted
back in while that's going i'm just
gonna make my quick
flour cornmeal batter for the shrimp
really just
eyeballing this it's a lot of a lot of
salt but it's okay
and because the shrimp are soaking in
the buttermilk
it's gonna make sure that the cornmeal
and flour actually adheres to it so you
get that crust
i actually feel really good about the
shrimp i know i keep saying that and it
fails but
i legitimately think the shrimp are
gonna be easy and like cook in
no time um okay the ribs look great
they're virgin on blackened but
[Music]
they look great i think i just need to
cut one to
test
it's not bad a little salty which i
personally like but that's fine
it's totally fine i feel really good
about this i think we can move on to the
shrimp
i'm going to dip my buttermilk shrimp
into the cornmeal
put it on here right up
sounds like it's frying it's like
that was a town impersonation do you
think it's ready okay
it is raw stuff it looks disgusting
so i think i need to try it for five
minutes
maybe higher heat too this is not my
mail
this is not my meal confidence level is
like a four
like a five it's a five
[Music]
five you guys
i think the shrimp have betrayed me this
looks really bad
so shrimpy it's cooked
[Music]
okay i'm gonna pivot scratch the po boy
i'm gonna rinse these off gonna put a
little dry rub on it it's just gonna be
a little
spiced shrimp slider we've got some salt
i've got some pepper got some paprika
don't need tiny bit of cayenne mix it up
pour out my shrimpies one shrimp at a
time
again i really really really want this
to work i've had to redo every single
thing today
like multiple times
shrimp skirt oh my god
it's so salty
[Music]
hmm
so salty it's kind of good but like
guys i'm so sorry i am i'm gonna wash
the shrimp off
again and re-spice them but i know the
cook time so it's gonna go really
smoothly this time
it's seasoned properly now so i'm gonna
do a bunch of shrimp at once
knock it out i know how much to do start
got all my slider not po boy slider
ingredients
ready to go shrimp is about to come out
beautiful
oh okay i'm gonna put some remoulade on
both sides
a little bit of the shredded romaine
a very big tomato and then two shrimp
nice slider done
my sliders are ready to go i'm gonna
finish plating up my entree i've got the
ribs the corn pudding
i'm gonna top it with some scallions and
lastly i have the
cherry torch gonna just dust some
powdered sugar on it before serving
and then it's taste tester time we made
it
this is my friend michi i'm nichie and
she's gonna taste test my three-course
meal
and i am so excited okay first course
we've got spiced shrimp sliders
wow i love anything in sandwich form so
this this is already oh my god i'm so
sorry this is awesome
that tastes amazing though holy crap are
there such a juicy piece of shrimp in
there
yeah i love that oh my goodness okay
course number two
yes we've got ribs and corn pudding
have you had corn pudding before no i
don't think i have actually i've had it
like twice so
i'm not angry at that at all actually i
kind of like it yeah yeah yeah it almost
reminds me like a macaroni and cheese
texture with like you know this meat
here the like
ribs you gotta totally totally just go
straight in there
they're not like full of the bones but
the key to a good rib is a delicious
flavor and now it's got delicious flavor
that might be one of the best ribs that
i've had like
in a while you're kind of killing it oh
my god okay so for dessert we've got
a cherry torch okay like a cherry cake
okay
i don't like cherry this is really good
yeah it's really surprising when you get
the actual fruit in there
it's very nice like refreshing yeah i
really love this
alexis you are thebomb.com oh my god
thank you so much
the most important question yes what do
you think i made this with i can't
believe all this came from one device
i feel like it has to be something
that's actually meant to be cooked with
i feel like you have to have some kind
of oven like a toaster oven let's say
it's toasted
toaster have a great guess okay all
three of these were made
in an air fryer okay makes sense
yeah that makes sense that makes sense
you did freaking awesome
this is amazing thank you for having me
i'm gonna go ahead and say that you know
like i said love a sandwich situation
this is my favorite i appreciate you
guys
thank you so much for beating me i'll
see you later
you know it's been a it's been a really
long day this was really hard for me but
nietzsche really made it better she made
me feel good about things i need to take
this newfound confidence with
nietzsche's praise and take it into the
next few days
[Music]
does this go inside i don't know what to
do
i think you've broken me this is the end
[Music]
welcome back to chef out of water i'm
alexis a chef who's always
up for a challenge we've taken to you
internet to ask
what weird appliance i should make a
three-course meal with
and i'm so excited to see what i've got
next
ready three two one
um
this is a joke i'm speechless
there's a oh there's two saws there's a
drill a heat gun and a hammer
this is really upsetting i don't know
what i can do
i need some time i know you can use
a saw to cut meat it's what butchers do
that doesn't feel crazy
there's a blender people make sauces it
looks like the heat gun
has quite a bit of heat they can get
like up to 1000 degrees which is pretty
cool i mean that's hotter than most
ovens so i'm not feeling confident right
now
listen the silver lining is that it
seems like when i have
unusual tools sometimes things go better
than when i have real kitchen appliances
if that can happen today that would be
fantastic
okay i've got a plan we'll see if it
works it's gonna be you know rustic
homey
we'll see i'm gonna have ryan go to the
store while i get everything ready here
ryan
for my first course i'm going to make a
charred little gem
caesar salad with some crispy prosciutto
i'm going to start easy by making the
dressing
i've had a safety training so i feel
fairly comfortable with all these tools
please do not try this at home
this is not for home use usually i would
make a
paste from garlic and anchovies but
i can't do that with a saw so i'm gonna
smash it with a hammer
that was efficient got some anchovies
here i know they're
fairly polarizing but i would honestly
eat this whole jar
oh they're so good
this is maybe even more efficient than a
knife i'm not gonna lie
this is weird
it's a beautiful paste this is exactly
how it should look
i'm gonna go wash my hands and wash this
hammer off
okay moving on i'm gonna prep my lemon
with my saw
nice i've been given this very handy
attachment
for the drill
so bad
maybe it should be going the other way
oh i reverse it
cool there yeah i'm gonna add some parm
into the anchovy paste i'm gonna add a
little mustard there we go
beautiful add a little pinch of salt
some pepper
and i'm gonna add two egg yolks the
easiest way to get egg yolks out
is to crack them into a bowl and just
use your hands to
really delicately go back and forth and
get it
out like that so i've got a blender
attachment
so far so good i mean this is this is
pretty much what i would do
at home i mean i wouldn't do this at
home but i would get it to this stage it
looks great
i'm going to add the olive oil to make
an emulsion and actually this makes it
even easier than if i was like using
hand whisk because i can actually just
drizzle it in like drop by drop until it
forms i can add my lemon i can't use a
juicer today so
just squeezing it in give it a taste
mmm that is pretty damn good i'm gonna
have ryan put this in the fridge and
then i'm gonna move on to the rest of
the salad
i'm going to make some crispy prosciutto
with a heat gun so the heat guns get
really hot so you want to always do it
well you actually don't want to do this
at home ever but i want to do this on a
metal tray
so that it doesn't burn and again we're
going rustic so just a few
torn pieces of prosciutto
you know everyone kept warning me that
this was gonna be super hot but it's not
feeling that way yet so maybe it takes a
minute to like get crazy
wow okay it's happening it's happening
it's pretty cool the fat from the
prosciutto like immediately seizes up
and kind of melts away
it's like not the most efficient but it
works i'm actually really happy
with the prosciutto it's like beautiful
crispy bits
i think i can move on to the next part
i'm gonna make croutons and i'm gonna
saw them
this bread is so squishy that the saw is
not doing much
[Music]
you know i'm gonna use my hands to just
tear it up sometimes there's no better
tool than your hands
and these can actually go on here
because i'm going to drizzle
the croutons with olive oil and then use
the heat gun to make them look a little
crispy
it smells like we're in a bakery this is
great
the olive oil makes it taste more like a
crouton where otherwise it just tastes
kind of like toast
croutons took a little bit of time so
far the most time consuming thing
but honestly they look beautiful i'm
gonna move on to my greens
i'm gonna use the saw again
so pretty maybe i want to quarter it
beautiful i'm actually so excited about
this the salad is one of my dinner party
staples and i feel like it's coming
together in a really
beautiful way confidence level is like
you know things could change but
salad 10. i'm gonna just drizzle these
with some oil and i'm just gonna get
them
lightly charred i think having the char
just adds a little more
texture and some smoky flavor okay i'm
gonna move on to
my next course skipping ahead and going
to do my full dessert course
for dessert i'm going to make bruleed
pineapple with a dollop of whipped cream
and
shaved chocolate and i'm thrilled to
report i'm going to start with the
whipped cream and for once
i have a beater all i have asked for
since i started the show
is to have a beater i always have to do
this by hand and it takes like 20
minutes and i'm exhausted my wish has
been answered here we go
you know here's the thing i've only got
one beater not two and it's still going
to take some time but it's
way better than doing it by hand
i take back what i said doing this by
hand would be easier this has been like
20 minutes and it's like
soupy still i'm gonna add a little sugar
one day i will measure something
it works it's just not efficient i think
this is
as good as it's gonna get i'm not gonna
get stiff peaks which is fine but more
of a like
loosey-goosey swoopy time
for some fun stuff start with chocolate
got a little salt this is kind of like a
knife that feels easy
just gonna this is great
i just want to sprinkle this over top so
i don't need that much
okay the pineapple in the sole i would
assume that
this actually could be very smart
because pineapples are a paint cut and
i don't know
cool i think this big blade is like
pretty helpful
it feels weird and it feels different
but that's not a bad thing
okay i want this cord i don't have a
knife but i have this little saw so i
think i can just go
my confidence level is
seven okay pineapple rings next up i'm
gonna just put some sugar over the
pineapple
torch it and it should get caramelized
and kind of hardened and beautiful but
let's see
some of the sugar crystals are
dissolving
okay the sugar is starting to bubble
you know it looks like it's starting to
caramelize but it's taking a really long
time the heat gun does work but it's not
super efficient
oh my god okay one pineapple has taken
about 20 minutes
and it looks beautiful it smells amazing
it smells like deeply intensely
caramelized and like fruity and sweet
but this is crazy i'm gonna do one more
and call it a day you know i'm not gonna
spend my day just heating up pineapple
i've been with these two pineapple
slices for about 45 minutes now so i'm
going to move on
last thing i have to do taking the
pineapple away
i'm going to make a raw fennel celery
and apple slaw a bit of mustard a bit of
mayo
and scallops which i'm not sure how it's
gonna turn out but
everything's worked so far so just gotta
hope for the best i
am gonna start with the fennel and this
time i'm gonna use
my little baby slaw my little baby saw
for my slaw there we go
okay taking off these tams
i'm gonna save these because i think
it'd be nice to toss some of the fennel
fronds into the slaw
okay my little saw isn't quite big
enough so i'm gonna
move on to the big one it's a rough cut
let me tell you
like this is not a pretty smooth knife
situation
oh maybe this saw i'm trying to cut out
the core of the fennel which is really
hard and generally you don't want to eat
it
it's a lot of work i keep saying with
all these episodes like give me heat
blah blah blah and i'm
taking for granted like a knife it's
really making me appreciate
the most basic of tools
oh god i think that's enough i think i'm
going to move on to the
celery nice
wow it is a rough situation i'm also
destroying this cutting board i'm so
sorry
i mean the celery is much easier than
fennel i think just because of the size
and the texture okay done with the
celery that's plenty
now the apple i'm using granny smith
apples which
are bright and crunchy you know i
haven't made the slaw but it's a pretty
classic combination
okay this is actually fairly efficient
okay this feels dangerous
actually alumina i would take the
anchovy over an apple any day i've got
my
slaw it looks really rough it looks like
a child cut it i'm gonna make my
dressing
i've got some kewpie mayonnaise which is
a type of japanese mayonnaise
made with egg yolks and rice vinegar so
it's got more of a tangy rich flavor
and some whole grain mustard oh no i
have to cut the lemon too
and that's an oil this is
cool adding a little pepper a little bit
of salt
mixing it again
[Music]
okay i think i need more mayonnaise
it's a bit too tangy i want it to be a
little creamier
[Music]
you know the secret to being a good cook
is tasting along the way
so if you're tasting along the way you
can make fixes like this so i'm just
going to add the whole thing
and i'm just going to use my hands to
toss
cool okay i'm gonna throw this in the
fridge and then the scallops
okay the last thing i have to do is to
sear some scallops
with a heat gun i thought that i could
oil this tray
and then kind of heat it up a bit with
the heat gun add the scallop
heat the top i'm also going to season it
i'm going to do a quick season it's just
salt and pepper
pretty easy okay we got a bunch of trays
really safe this is oiled i think
that'll work and i'm just gonna heat it
if i was searing scallops at home on a
stove top i would do it over high heat
for like a minute or two on each side
they go
really fast and you want scallops to be
like just
barely cook through you really don't
want them to get tough so
i thought the heat gun might have a
similar principle
it's getting pretty hot so
oh should i oil the top maybe
it's cooking you know the scallop has
gone from being kind of translucent to
opaque which is
what what i want oh i don't even have a
butter knife jesus
i'm gonna saw a scallop
it's delicious that is like the coolest
thing i've ever done the pepper gets
kind of
i don't say burnt but more fragrant
and aromatic which is kind of nice it's
like a warm peppery thing
from the heat it's funny i thought the
pineapple was gonna be the easiest thing
i thought just you know brulee in it
it's no problem but it turns out the
scallops
mvp baby i'm gonna get this all plated
up and then it's time for my taste
tester
this is my friend tatomi hello she was
also the taste tester on
a last season's finale so i'm extra
excited to have her back because i think
things got a little weirder this time
oh later i mean last time you knew we
were like in the woods you knew what was
happening
okay i i'm excited because i really
don't know okay are you ready for the
first course yes
for our first course we have a charred
little gem caesar with some croutons and
some crispy prosciutto oh
i like it should i get like a little bit
of everything you can you can have one
bite you can have many bites
you know do do what you think this
dressing is really good
thanks there's like so many elements
it's like nice and crispy
nice and charred nice and toasty this is
a winner
thank you okay let me get the second
dish okay we've got
a fennel apple celery slaw
some whole grain mustard some fennel
fronds and then some scallops
okay i mean this is so fancy
so juicy it's so good what do you think
about the cook on the scallops
besides perfect i mean i love
is there a char thing happening here i
don't know is there a char thing
happening here right there it kind of is
but this salad is also very refreshing
which goes with the seafood this is
delicious
oh thank you okay we've got one more
dessert
is a little abstract oh my god they're a
brulee
pineapple with some whipped cream and
chocolate shavings
this is my favorite thing to do when i
go camping
i love grilling pineapples oh my god
that's amazing so good
i'm actually i'm gonna i'm gonna have a
bite too
[Music]
wow there's like a crunch there's a real
crunch like a creme brulee top
yeah okay i think i know well you think
you know
i think so okay what do you think my
guess is
you're close but you're not right for
this meal
i was given only hand tools
what like these huh
how did you do that and this oh
and a heat gun oh that's where the jar
came from
but this one i had a fancy little
blender attached yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then i didn't have any knives i
only had saws
oh we're going this is the hammer helped
make the dressing you would have never
guessed yeah
because my brain is blown i had a total
panic when i first saw it i was like
there's no way
but there's a way well thank you very
much i learned something new
and i'm gonna finish this you guys i did
it
i had such an amazing time it's been
such a wild ride
let me know if you've used any of these
tools to make something fun in the
comments
see you soon